the staff are navy grandson developed
because the android team
I'm here today for a design by
talk about a very important subject
that you have to keep in mind when it comes to
design your android app
be you a design where a seller ok
which are the independent density pixels
but what is this
even the android devices they
have different pixel density
we measure this in points by
adopt sprint and prevention of
ipi
or how close the pixels are
one of the others there an example has four
pictures to the letter in different né dp isso
one can realize that the more
ipi
the image gets better that I have more
pixels dots forming this
closest to each other and to the
picture looks better
ok but how does she always stay a bit right?
the android devices screens us
were grouped into logical groups t
Good thing we call density
pixel logic or logical English
pixel teeth
in this case the people of some inclusive
the friendly games we'll see on the table and
I have for example 130 dp es
We call it MDP and that's the
density ratio that you will use
basis for calculating the remaining cities
size of your images eg the
people have there for example 240v saucers that
the friendly name known as hpi and
The scale is one and a half times the
remembering people must have seen
this neighbor name already these names and mdp i
is prince where you are a project
android and will find the folder of the drug the
mdp ii trace for example is there and will have
the images you are going to use to
every logical group of this good continues I
I have 320 that we call x hpi
is twice an image of ipi and
density of 480 that the xx hpi or
three times the mdp scale is then
this way you can plan with
give them your image in the best way
It's just to explain a little better.
contextualize you how this is done
call
is not pixel or abbreviated
as dp or ipi you can find
a place is a pixel virtual drive
equivalent to 1 and its physical on a screen
of hundreds of fish
remembering that I already said the word
low density for you to make your
Accounts are there and it is resized
proportionately to larger screens or
minors
There we go because there is a tablet and
a phone for example where I want
for 200 dp is and wants to know how much
pixel worry on this screen for
example 200 pixels in May ipi because
because it is the base density as it had
said then 1 dp
it's worth a pixel the ipi scene on wikipedia
I have a phone where I have
400 pixels why because a screen xh dp
where the scale is twice the size of the
mp is only to have a notion the tip of a
human finger has dropped an average of 50
dps so it is very important to remember
In addition to designing a button an
application is otherwise from here
little will have been looking there where
will hit the app so you have
this in mind
Ok folks and summon eyepiece button
little button is big
well come on the first thing, remembering
a pixel exception of fish is a dp in
santa cecilia dp this is for you then
make the rule of three there we will put more
basic 2 pixels 320 ipi
It's good exercise so I have to
nexus 7 in the new version is where I have
a 7 inch screen
she is of resolution x hp are remembering
is twice the resolution of the MDP
good and in pixel she has 1920 by 1,200
people calculator made the bill
Head is good, come on, the answer is
960 for 610 thousand do not go right because he has
beat the proportion so you do not
be concerned about positioning that
in this end in that place you do not work
always with this virtual resolution that
it will be is a veil for all
Good resolutions
and the point is talking to the image
It's good and in case you have a business.
called the corner
independent pixels objects like sp
will also start from the base of mdp itabom
and it is equivalent to 1 dp né
to 100% of the source in scale, reminding
that the user for reasons of
accessibility and can resize
global source
so careful not only design who is
you raise the text to reality
it is not that, it has a function of its own
android with sensitivity and you
will work with sp
Well, do not forget that, good. We close.
and if that part of that part of those tips
Let's have a look, first time at
specify the layouts in de peta
images and layout always using dp and no
case of image clip gené in all
Sizes are good all the resolutions to
You should know this better than
entered is that you have a targeting
square plus the image is dangerous including
losing image quality is very
important that you avoid the
resizing by creating images of the
correct sizes good and with us already
had previous vadim photo
do not forget personal texts in sp
So it's good now with these tips and
understanding well what are ipi souls
ipi also you have all the basis for
make a layout that works on any
screen any size and projects
way too easy
It's good to see you up against
more